toria thank you for that well as we as  you shop for independence day  celebrations expect less bang for your  buck this year inflation is hitting the  fireworks industry the ceo of major  retailer phantom fireworks says many of  the items they stocked come from  overseas and shipping costs have  skyrocketed 2019 we paid approximately  11 000 a container and this year we're  paying close to 40 000 a container  he says supply chain problems started  during the pandemic when public  fireworks shows were canceled leading  millions of people to make their own  displays despite the higher prices  zoldan tells us there is more inventory  this year so while you may spend more  you can likely find what you want  safe and sane fireworks sales also begin  next week they're the only ones approved  for use here in clark county purchase  them from the local stands to ensure  that they are legal  remember you could face a 500 fine if  you're caught using illegal fireworks